hello everybody and welcome to part 10
of let's play from dust all right where
we left off oh this this woman's a
trooper here she survived like three
tidal waves but I don't know why she's
going all the way back to this one when
there's a tribe right there but I won't
judge her I'll let her do her own thing
and need to get this water out of here
so that I can repopulate that village
cuz I know I might be cruel and trying
to blow my guys out but I don't want to
make him drown every five minutes I'll
get it out of yours sand always wants a
piece of me I mean who doesn't
oh yeah so awesome alright almost got it
almost there there we go I'm not sure
how my people are gonna deal with the
constantly shape changing landscape but
whatever they're tough I can do it
alright
and let's see more exploding through
this is where the glowing tree grew
there we go okay now I need to just a
little more of a channel here boom bang
II oh yeah
okay I don't need to go there just yet
um do you think there's not much else
more not much else more that's what much
more else
I never mind screw that sentence I
abandon it
alright now ones repopulating oh this
would need to be repopulated as well
totem of fertility there's a lot of
totems of fertility I'm not exactly
surprised that oh I can move it it's not
safe to build a village here
okay let me move it what the heck
well screw you village I don't even need
you alright
what's going on here what's going on
alright lady what do you got what do you
want to show me memory vegetation okay
another thing that I'll have to read
later maybe at the end of this series
I'll do a quick play-by-play of each one
of these memories you can pause the
video and read it if you if you're
really interested I I know some of you
are probably really interested in this
stuff but um I I don't want to waste too
much time so maybe at the end maybe at
the end okay alright now I need to
figure out how the heck to move this
thing or get my people here it's not
safe to build a village here there's too
much water oh that that that was
stopping you really really Wow
how pathetic all right that figured out
cuz I'm so smart I don't get these outta
here
don't like them anyway boom come in come
here a boom a bang II oh yeah
boom bury me bang oh no did I just kill
I think I just killed two people
oh I'm such an [ __ ] oh no I saw a
little dust a little spot above that
guy's head like that and then they just
disappeared oh oh no I'm a
mass-murdering evil evil evil god oh no
or breath rather whatever they want to
call him I don't know what that did what
what is that
I don't know vegetation to grow we need
water
so let's her the off sorry let's get
these things releasing their water oh
not too much water I'll flood my things
all right Oh squirt it on out insert
your own joke here but do oh that's what
the power does okay it repels water I
probably shouldn't have dumped it all
out then but I do
Oh what just exploded Allen whoops oh no
oh that doesn't look good
what happened did they swell up too much
and explode oh gotta love that beep drop
the bass on ya boom boom all right
enough of this is dangerous Babu
alright okay spread palms across half
the territory Wow good for me look at
that
oh yeah and I just need um more I guess
oh here's some water she's okay now
there sploosh sploosh II ahh boom bang
BAM oh yeah I must assume that all my
villages are gonna be fine because
they're obviously all tidal wave
repellent sploosh
I don't even know how these water plants
got this much water stockpiled but who
cares all right animals love them not
really they're creepy but I like getting
close to a hundred percent of vegetation
gives me one of those memories that I
won't show you ha ha ha ha ha all right
almost there almost there
little more little more Itamar BAM
oh yeah the trees battle with the wind
our shaman heard the voice of the
ancients there in all right
whoa shakey I unlocked a new map for
challenge mode uh I didn't even know
there was a challenge mode whatever
whatever it ain't no thang it ain't a
challenge for me I don't think people
can quite get through there but come
here you
blow up a little more um not sand sand
always wants to join into the party and
it is not invited all right that should
be clear enough what do you need help
with who needs help
what pathetic loser needs help yeah I
didn't think so
all right come on now oh hello baby
they're leading the pack I see oh no
you're not sorry you could be you could
be leader keep going oh there's that
monster yeah uh hey creepy all right
Oh what's with its face Oh oh it looks
like the brain monster from Starship
Troopers ah
by the way Starship Troopers another
good member another good movie her I
don't think I've mentioned any other
moves but Starship Troopers that's a
good one
great CG for its time the sequels and
not so much it's funny thing like the
sequels were released in the 2000s like
2004 and later I even think the third
one but they're they're they're CG was
it looked like puppets compared to the
1996 version anyway enough about that
alone now huh oh I'm here oh you want
for me
all right moving on
all right what do we got what do we got
yeah nothing
all right looks kind of interesting
oh no land I might be a problem high
tides oh oh seven yeah Pandya Banke
Bihari Danza honey to change America
table puto or AA very peppery
balagia Lackey body okay oh good job
finally you guys didn't need to get my
help to populate you don't need me to
tell you to get it on not where my
shoulder um let's see I got this that's
over there one of my powers says engulf
all uh that seems pretty serious I like
it all right I don't think I don't have
very much land to work with but maybe I
could
damn this up um yeah I don't know where
that water's all coming from because
it's all flowing out but I don't know
where I guess the tide moves in then
type of them go go quickly tides low oh
go go go go go hey maybe they're
actually gonna make it I never thought
this plan would work
come on amplify my breath Oh give me
that sand oh yeah oh you need my help
Oh too bad I'll move guys you don't have
long oh here it comes up out your oh
you're done so done can't even get up
that mountain I bet not so pathetic
losers oh there you go okay you're not
losers
you're all very cool people yay
alright whatever that power is I'm
pretty sure it's useful oh it looks like
the repel water one so probably very
useful what do you guys go get that
thing
Oh get out your sand is that thing
oh all right almost there
Oh nope nope no okay dude oh poor guy No
Oh live it's live all poor lady again
get it wrong I'm sorry and you are very
feminine but I can't see when I'm Way up
here or way out here all right anyway I
have to cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see you
guys in part 11 of let's play from dust
bye bye